[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich möchte heute mal wieder eine
von dunst orte machen und zwar gibt die
berühmte world water mailand orte die er
auch schon in dem galileo beitrag
gesehen habt also diese 3d motiv torte
in form einer wassermelone und mit
gesicht und so weiter ich mache heute
ist komplett rezept durch das heißt es
wird jetzt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
längeres video aber ich sage ich einfach
alle schritte wichtig ist dass ihr dabei
wird denkt dass ihr da mindestens zwei
tage einplanen
ich werde jetzt erstmal den boden also
den teig backen und die creme machen und
dann eben am nächsten tag dass ihr daran
die torte dekoriert man an einem tag
fliegt muss zwar schon hin
aber es ist so viel aufwand und so viel
wartezeit vor allem im kühlschrank dass
wir besser also dass ihr besser dran
seid werdet es einfach auf zwei tage
aufgeteilt so ich mache jetzt zuerst mal
den kuchenteig und zeigt euch da jetzt
mal die zutaten
ich brauche vier eier 200 gramm zucker
eine prise salz und etwas vanille
extrakt für den geschmack 200 milliliter
mineralwasser 200 milliliter öl da habe
ich ein neutrales sonnenblumenöl
ich habe eine tube lebensmittelfarbe und
zwar nehme ich da diese verpasste eine
rote und brauche wahrscheinlich auch die
komplette truppe weil wird es richtig
richtig gut brauchen
die farbe ist zwar sehr konzentriert
aber dennoch brauchen wir etwas mehr
farbe dann brauche ich 300 gramm mehl
und 100 g speisestärke eine packung
backpulver und ich habe hier so backfest
der schoko drops die sollen nämlich
später dann die wassermelone gerne
darstellen
und das ist dann ebenso dieser effekt da
drin diese menge reicht es für 2000 ich
werde aber später noch mal die gleiche
menge machen das heißt ihr braucht diese
menge einfach im doppelten portion das
ganze geht jetzt ziemlich einfach und
auch ganz schnell
ich gehe es zuerst die eier in die
schüssel dann kommt da
etwas salz sind dazu und vanille extrakt
davis tier nehm ich immer gern vanille
extrakt weil es halt einfach intensiver
schmeckt das ist echter vanille kein
künstlicher vanille wsv vanillinzucker
zum beispiel und ich habe es halt echt
konzentriert da drin und es ist wirklich
lang angeblich und jetzt gebe ich hier
noch den zucker mit rein und lässt das
ganze jetzt richtig cremig verrühren das
dauert es ungefähr vier bis fünf minuten
[Musik]
und wenn die masse dann richtig schön
cremig ist gebe ich jetzt hier an der
stelle schon mal die lebensmittelfarbe
mit rein
denn dann muss ich sie später nicht mehr
im teig schaber nochmal unter rühren und
ich schlag dann die luft aus dem teig
wieder raus deswegen kommt jetzt direkt
mit rein
es geht auch die richtig konzentriert
problem ist erst mal so da guckt ihr
einfach wie intensiv rot ihr das haben
möchte
sobald sich dann wackeln das auch noch
so ein bisschen verstärkt
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich hier machte zwei
flüssigkeiten mit rhein und ruhr die
gleich bei niedriger stufe kommt runter
und bevor ich jetzt den teig fertig
stelle also ich mach das meistens immer
währenddessen schon aber ich möchte euch
das ist noch mal extra zeigen wenn ich
nämlich meine 2 battg rahmen einschlagen
und zwar mit 220 cm bank haben ihr könnt
natürlich wenn ihr jetzt nur einen habt
auch nur mit einem bakken
dann würde ich aber empfehlen die
teilmenge zu halbieren und ist auf zwei
mal zupacken
weil es hat einfach gleichmäßiger wird
ihr bekommt keine risse in den mittags-
und ich backe hat am liebsten mit back
rahmen weil die bewirken dass man eben
kürzeren kürzere bauzeit hat das bak
gleichmäßiger hoch und man hat einfach
ein schönes ergebnis so als wäre es ein
geschlagen das heißt ich schneide dir
mein bagdad vier ein bisschen größer als
jetzt den bug rahmen dann schlag ich
hier das erste mal oben
jetzt müsst ihr den bug am thema schön
festhalten und das ganze jetzt hier
drogen weg zwischendurch auf der magaths
streichen dann geht es nicht so leicht
auf und wenn solch einfacher fällt
könnte hier auch einfach so ein
geschirrtuch darunter lägen dann gut
damit weg hat es ihm so einfache tricks
tier dann einfach anwenden könnt dann
auf sie bis jetzt immer die naht so ein
bisschen an den rand damit wieder
aufgeht
[Musik]
nehme ich hier kurz die schlüssel weg
schnell denn die löffel ablage tropft
das alles nicht so dann habe ich nämlich
einfacher geht's gleich die trockenen
zutaten reinzuschieben jetzt nämlich
mail speisestärke nämlich immer ganz
gern weiß den teig geben lockerer macht
als jetzt nur mit mehl und backpulver
man muss nicht arbeitet mittelblocker
dadurch
das ganz schön rein 7 damit keine
klümpchen im teig gibt und es wird jetzt
auch bei niedriger stufe ganz kurz
eingerührt können jetzt auch mit per
hand machen dem schneebesen aber so
geht's halt schneller und einfacher
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich hier noch die
schokostückchen mit rein das sind
strallegg lass ich mich denn ich streue
ich oben drauf
hierdurch auch kurz unter und das ganze
wirklich nur ganz kurz damit jetzt keine
luft mehr ausschlag und das war's dann
auch schon
den backofen habe ich schon vorgeheizt
bevor ich mit dem teig angefangen habe
auf 170 grad ober und unterhitze das
schon immer ganz wichtig dass rasch und
warm ist und jetzt gleichmäßig auf die 2
förmchen aufteilen
jetzt nehme ich doch die restlichen
schokostückchen die gebe ich hier oben
drauf dann weiß ich nämlich dass ich
auch schaukel stücke ganz schön verteilt
habe samira übrigens grab auch ein
kindergarten und futtert hund jetzt gebe
ich das ganze in den backofen für etwa
35 minuten ich mache danach direkt die
stäbchen probe mit dem zahnstocher
und wenn der teig fertig ist nämlich in
rauslassen komplett abkühlen und die
zwischenzeit nutzen wir jetzt gleich um
unsere kanal zu stellen
ich habe c die zutaten für die kanal
stehen und zwar mache ich jetzt eine
kanals aus weißer schokolade und sahne
ich nehme zwei schokolade weil ich hätte
den effekt möchte dass die torte später
aussieht wie eine wassermelone und
dieser kann es ist dann packt euch diese
weiße schicht von der wassermelone
deswegen also ich offizieren in becher
sahne dessen 200 gramm und 600 gramm
weiße schokolade schon ein stückchen
gebrochen
ihr braucht aber für das rezept die
doppelte menge
ich habe jetzt nur einen teil schon
vorbereitet damit es schon abkühlt und
mache jetzt deswegen den zweiten teil
für euch jetzt gebe ich die sahne in den
topf und schloss die erst einmal
aufkochen
[Musik]
und wenn die sonne dann kocht nehme ich
die hitze runter als ich schon den herd
aus und gibt die schokostückchen direkt
mit rein
und dann schaue ich dass die schokolade
komplett mit der sahne bedecktes und
lass das jetzt ganz kurz so etwa eine
minute mal kurz stehen und dann fange
ich an zu hören
bis sich daneben die schokolade auf
lasst uns heute das so lange bis sich
die schokolade komplett mit der sahne
verbunden hat dann müsste auch am
topfboden so ein bisschen kratzen weil
sich da auf die schokolade festsetzt
aber das geht so mit schneebesen ganz
gut
und jetzt eben so lange rühren bis die
ganzen klümpchen weg sind jetzt will ich
das ganze wieder in diese schlüssel
zurück mit dem decke einfach damit ich
das gleich verschließen kann und das
dann abkühlen kann
und die zwei dinge also jetzt kuchenteig
vorbereiten kann rasch vorbereiten macht
ihr wirklich am ersten tag und lass es
dann am besten einfach bis zum nächsten
tag abkühlen
die ganache werde ich jetzt abdecken und
sieht der schweiz immer temperatur
abkühlen lassen
bei uns ist es halt ziemlich warm hatte
wir haben glaube ich 30 grad in der
küche das heißt ich lasse jetzt über
nacht hier in der küche stehen und wenn
ich sie dann benutzer am nächsten tag
musste ein bisschen fester sein aber da
gebe ich sie dann nur für etwa zehn
minuten im kühlschrank denn zu fest darf
sie auch nicht sein so sehen jetzt die
fertigen böden aus die anderen zwei
kommen gleich noch aus dem ofen raus und
ich habe jetzt die hier bereits komplett
abkühlen lassen und schlagt die jetzt
mit ihrer frischhaltefolie ein und gibt
es jetzt über nacht in den kühlschrank
und dann habt ihr die arbeit für den
ersten tag schon erledigt die
kanalstrecke abkühlen die böden können
abkühlen und dann geht am nächsten tag
direkt weiter mit als untergrund so ein
skateboard da kann ich nämlich schön
drauf arbeiten und später die torte
bewegen so wie ich sehen möchte die
stelle ich mit auf 1
drehteller und damit da jetzt die torte
gleich drauf klebt nehme ich jetzt hier
etwas von meiner kanals als das so sieht
jetzt die konsistenz aus wenn sie eben
bei zimmertemperatur abgekühlt
gut bei uns ich sitze gerade wirklich
wirklich sehr warm deswegen stelle ich
sie gleich auch bisschen kühl bevor ich
später die torte einstreichen
10 40 grad sein
aber ich streiche zu wissen was hier
drauf kann das auch gleich wieder
abdecken damit jetzt einfach der
tortenboden drauf klebt
hier habe ich jetzt die fertigen böden
alle die sind jetzt alles schön
abgekühlt und jetzt müsst ihr mal direkt
zum spielplatz probleme aber ich mache
das jetzt nämlich direkt den ersten
boden
den gebe ich auf einen teig retter
trotten bretter das backpapier ab jetzt
sieht man auch schon diese
schokostückchen bot die sind alle auf
den boden gesunken
das ist aber nicht schlimm und dann
benutze ich jetzt meine torten säge denn
ich möchte diese böden nicht einfach so
auseinandersetzen sondern das eben noch
ein bisschen geschmack mit reinkommen
bisschen feuchtigkeit mit rein kommt
werde ich sie gleich noch trinken
schneidet jetzt auch nur einmal durch
durch und es geht halt am besten wenn
der teig vorher im kühlschrank war schön
abgekühlt ist dann bröselt endlich mehr
so arg jetzt nehme ich mit einem zweiten
teil bretter die torte also den boden
weg und ich will das eigentlich darauf
stürzen deswegen lege ich das am besten
drauf
einmal um trinkt ja das war ein bisschen
hin und her aber es ist ziemlich einfach
das heißt ihr kurz stehen und die
tortenböden schneide ich jetzt gleich
immer nach und nach aber weil ich sie
jetzt tränken möchte brauche ich es zwei
zutaten und zwar habe ich jetzt hier
einmal so ein erdbeer sirup ich möchte
das jetzt einfach noch ein bisschen
geschmack mit reinkommt geht deswegen
app per sirup mit rein das ist also das
ist einfach erdball mit zucker alkohol
frei und damit wissen soll damit rein
kommt ihr wisst ja ich mag zitrone gebe
ich jetzt auch zitronensaft betreibt ich
nehme zwei zitronen prestin sagt aus
[Musik]
dann gebe ich jetzt den erdball sirup
wird dazu einfach so nach gefühl nach
geschmack mit dieser mischung werde ich
jetzt den boden trinken
auch nicht so viel also ein paar mal mit
pinsel drüber und das stelle ich jetzt
kurz zur seite
denn ich muss er jetzt die tortenböden
übereinander stapeln damit ich so ein
grundgerüst ab um die wassermelone
zuschneiden und weil das jetzt so
aufeinander nicht kleben würde und die
tortenböden sich dann verschieben würden
mache ich jetzt noch mal eine separate
creme ihr könnt es jetzt zwar auch mit
der kanal machen aber die kann ich jetzt
nicht einfärben weil er die paar passten
nicht auf web basis sind sondern eben
auf wasserbasis und deswegen mache ich
jetzt so eine lockere leichte frischkäse
creme auch und habe hier die zutaten die
teuren anzeigen
ich habe jetzt hier nämlich 100 gramm
weiche butter 100 g frischkäse und 100
gramm puderzucker und die creme möchte
ich eben dass die auch heute wird sieht
man es ja später im anschnitt und das
möchte ich eben nicht die weiche butter
mit dem puderzucker schön verrühren
[Musik]
dann kommt da auch der frischkäse mit
ryan an zu wenig butter puderzucker
verrührt haben
und ich geh jetz auch direkt die
lebensmittelfarbe mit dazu damit die
creme genauso schön rot wird wie die
böden die fettige cremes habe ich jetzt
umgefüllt damit ich leichte damit
hantieren kann und die streicher sitzt
hier auf den boden nicht zu viel und
auch nicht bis ganz zum rand denn bei
dieser krebs jetzt ganz wichtig dass sie
später nicht mit dem von der in
berührung kommt weil die wird denn von
dort auflösen weil sie einfach zu viel
feuchtigkeit enthält durch den
frischkäse
jetzt kommt doch immer so ein bisschen
creme dann der zweite boden
[Musik]
dann wird dieser wieder getränkt und das
machen wir jetzt im wechsel und ich
schneide und starb lädt alle tortenböden
einfach aufeinander
bis die torte richtig schön hoch ist
[Musik]
die torte ist jetzt fertig gestapelt und
so müsste sie jetzt mindestens für eine
stunde in den kühlschrank geben damit
die einzelnen schichten jetzt schon fest
werden die buttercreme im innern
festwirt und ich sie dann später schön
in form schneiden kann und das mache ich
jetzt kurzen und langsamen uns gleich
wieder die torte sitzt schön kalt und
jetzt wird das schöne in form
geschnitten und dafür hab ich mich jetzt
hingesetzt denn ab jetzt geht alles
etwas länger weil wir jetzt einfach ganz
viel detailarbeit mit drin steckt und
wir haben jetzt also ein zylinder und
jetzt muss ich das ganze so ein bisschen
in so eine ovale form schneiden haben
jetzt da für so ein kleines blech
darunter gelegt da kann dann der
kuchenteig immer schön reinfallen und
dann könnte einfach oben beginnen und
das ganze eben schön rundlich schneiden
und wenn du die rundung dann so
einigermaßen habt könnt ihr schon mal
die erste schicht kanalstr auf streichen
also meine tochter ist jetzt noch nicht
perfekt rund ich setze jetzt gleich noch
ein bisschen tag darauf damit ich hier
oben auch schon schön rubel habe aber
erstmal mit bisserl ganache versiegeln
weil der teig jetzt extrem bröselig ist
das eben in mehreren schichten machen
die erste schicht sorgt jetzt dafür dass
der teig bröselt und dann später eben
keine bösen mal runterfallen
und dann kann man nämlich gleich viel
besser arbeiten
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt komplett eingestrichen
und geben jetzt erstmal den kühlschrank
bei mir daheim ist es auch extrem warm
ich glaub ich hab echt locker über 35
grad die kammer schmilzt ständig vor
sich hin
also im sommer ist schon eine große
herausforderung eine von bam torte zu
machen aber das wird schon klappen
ich gebe den kühlschrank für etwa eine
halbe stunde damit die erste kremitz mal
fest wird und dann für immer gleich
weiterarbeiten die ghanas gebe ich jetzt
auch im kühlschrank
sonst wird jetzt immer fleißig die torte
ist schön kalt und bevor ich jetzt
weiter mit der kanadische einstreiche
und die form eben voll ende muss ich
jetzt erst mal noch den mund eben
ausschneiden weil ich möchte auch das
wort erteilen sondern dreidimensional
mund hat und dafür zeichne ich mir jetzt
hier mit einem messer das war ein
bisschen vor schöner großer mund
die wird dann gleich ausfüllen können
und dann schneide ich das mit dem messer
ein
[Musik]
und dann am besten mit so einem löffel
rausholen leichter und das ist jetzt ein
stück was ich jetzt hier oben dran
setzen kann um gleich die torte oben
eben auch wieder rund zu bekommen
also spiele immer so ein bisschen
puzzlen
[Musik]
und jetzt nehme ich mir wieder die
kanals wenn ihr das jetzt ausgewählt
habt und dann streiche ich das jetzt in
den mund damit da jetzt auch wieder
verdichtet wird und nicht krümelt
und jetzt könnt ihr mit der restlichen
ganache die torte nochmal einstreichen
komplett dass wir eben richtig schöne
weiße schicht haben
der kuchen auch schön glatt wird und die
unterlage also der der untergrund für
den von dort eben richtig perfekt wird
ich hab die torte übrigens zwischendurch
immer wieder im kühlschrank gestellt
sind bei uns ist wirklich sehr warm und
ansonsten kann man nämlich damit gar
nicht arbeiten
[Musik]
jetzt muss ich wolters gesicht formen
und dafür nehme ich mir etwas weitere
modelle schokolade gibt so verpackt deko
schock heißt die und die könnt ihr jetzt
ganz einfach formen ich meine jetzt hab
ich auch ganz leicht denn jetzt in der
die temperaturen so hoch und das ist
schon richtig schön weich und damit für
mich mit rollen und lange schlangen und
form einfach wunsch auge nase usw und
klebt es alles direkt dran und als hilfe
könnt ihr euch jetzt ein modell werkzeug
nehmen und das gesicht so ein bisschen
vorzeichnen das seht es nicht komplett
aus der hand frei machen müsst
[Musik]
und ich mache mir so ein bisschen ein
müdes gesicht denn es ist sehr warm
als neuesten wolter auch zu wahren und
deswegen kriegt er zu angesicht
[Musik]
ich habe das grundgerüst fertig worte
ist jetzt gerade im kühlschrank und
nicht mal wer dich schon mal den vom
dorf vorbereiten
dafür habe ich jetzt hier drei päckchen
grünen von dort das sind immer 250 gramm
und damit müsste ich hinkommen und ich
habe auch ein päckchen geld und ich
möchte ein bisschen dass an manchen
stellen
der wollte ein bisschen heller ist also
so ein kleiner marmor effekt und so kann
man einfach auch die farbe des grünen
ist ein bisschen verändern
das ist ja so ein richtig schönes
ortsbild und wenn er ein bisschen geld
mit reingeht wird ebenso ein bisschen
heller grünton
[Musik]
und jetzt nehme ich mir hier etwas palm
in soft also etwas kokosfett für die
hände schließe damit ein klebt es
nämlich auch nicht so ich muss jetzt
nicht lange kneten denn davon deutsch
bei 30 grad in der küche sowieso schon
warm und weich
deswegen geht es jetzt ganz schnell
[Musik]
und jetzt kann ich denn von dort auf
etwas becker stecker aus rolf becker
stärke hilft dabei dass ich ihn schön
aus rollen kann ohne klümpchen ist es
auch dann klebt doch nicht und den rolle
ich jetzt so ungefähr zwei bis drei
millimeter dick aus oder dünn aus
m
ziemlich etwas schoko von dort das grün
lasse ich jetzt hier ganz kurz liegen
den ich mich erst mit auslegen und das
mache ich jetzt mit schoko von dort
könnte aber auch zum beispiel schwarz
benutzt einfach irgendwas dunkles damit
wir das in den mund reinlegen können den
jetzt auch kurz kneten und den ausrollen
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich etwas sagt rinn spray
sprühsystem wollte riefen den mund ich
wahrscheinlich nicht besonders lecker
muster jetzt durch und jetzt lege ich
den mund mit diesem schoko von dort aus
setzte sprüchen noch komplett mit dem
bug trance tricks wobei es hier so war
mich dass wir wirklich schon anfängt zu
schmelzen also der von dort wird auch so
daran haften
und dann könnt ihr jetzt diese große
decke nehmen und über ihn drüber legen
aufpassen dass er eben auch überall
bedeckt wird
und jetzt schön glatt streichen immer
von oben nach unten
zuerst mal mit den fingern und später
dann ein werkzeug und hier kann man sich
jetzt so ein bisschen entlang tasten
dann hat man auch wieder die formel
[Musik]
die überreste nehme ich jetzt mit seinem
marzipan messer weg erst mal ganz grob
damit es aus und stört
[Musik]
denn von dort können einfach wieder
zusammen kneten in einen gefrierbeutel
geben und in so eine tupper schüssel
geben im kühlschrank lagern und erhält
er euch da ein halbes jahr
also könnte immer wieder benutzen so und
den rest müsste jetzt schön mit den
fingern verstreichen
hier beim und muss man jetzt extrem
aufpassen dass er von dort nicht reißt
deswegen schneiden auch direkt ein
damit einfach die spannung des erst mal
weggeht
[Musik]
dann von unten jetzt richtig schön
formen
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich mir etwas weiße blüten
passte und damit vor mich jetzt die
augen
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich mir hier etwas pulver
farbe und zwar ist es so ein schönes
dunkelgrün und damit statt ihre ich
ihnen jetzt noch ein bisschen also den
schritt kann man gern auch weglassen
aber ich finde wenn man da so ein
bisschen schattierungen mit rein bringt
sieht etwas realistischer aus jetzt
können wir einfach irgendwo starten
[Musik]
ich sehe ich etwas palmen und gibt es
hier auf dieser unterlage
denn ich möchte jetzt wieder schön
verdecken und da gebe ich jetzt einfach
gleich bisschen schoko modelliermasse
drauf also schoko von dorn und kann das
damit schön verkleiden und das ist
einfach so ein bisschen mit den händen
kneten und dann immer wieder in falten
drauflegen da ist egal wie es aussieht
im prinzip sollte so ein bisschen die
erde oder interessant nachstellen
[Musik]
und wenn ihr das dann habt könnt ihr
jetzt den mund schön aus formen und zwar
habe ich jetzt hier ein stück roten von
dort könnte ist wenn ihr wollt cmc
pulver einarbeiten also zellulose pulver
denn dann wird davon da auch fest wobei
das jetzt nicht wichtig weil die zunge
soll sie jetzt gleich sowieso dem körper
anpassen oder dem kopf körper hat und
leider nehme ich wieder ein bisschen von
der blüten von dem von der bäcker stärke
und form ist hieraus eine zunge
hinten drücke ich sie jetzt auch etwas
flacher da wo sie dann im mund drin
endet und so sieht es eigentlich schon
gut aus und jetzt könnt ihr hier mit
seiner modelle werkzeug noch in die
mitte zu diesem streifen rain machen
[Musik]
mir das dann wieder so ein bisschen
zusammendrückt hab das schöne zu
das tolle an der bäcker stärke ich kann
sehr einfach wieder schön ab rudern
wegwischen
[Musik]
und es gebe ich jetzt auch mit etwas
palm ihn daran könnte natürlich auch im
zucker kleber benutzen
dem ist halt fahren deswegen hängt dort
und aus weißer blüten passte freue mich
jetzt noch drei zähne dafür einfach eine
kleine kugel dann das ganze zu einer
rolle formen und halbieren
die könnte dann so ein bisschen mit den
händen formen
die lasse ich jetzt hier ganz kurz
antrocknen und jetzt habe ich hier noch
mal zwei kleine kugeln aus schokoladen
von dort drückt die etwas flach das
werde jetzt die puppe dann kommt da ein
kleines stück weg denn ich möchte jetzt
direkt und das augenlid setzen damit man
auch wirklich sieht dass es ihm zur wahl
stehen der küche und die klebe ich jetzt
auch hier mit etwas palmen an
[Musik]
und dann noch zwei punkte aus blüten
passte mit drauf
[Musik]
und da nehme ich mir zum zahnstocher
recht da ein kleines stückchen ab steckt
es in den zahnreihen und jetzt können
doch den zahn entweder mit etwas zucker
kleber dran kleben oder einfach direkt
auch einstecken
[Musik]
und die letzten feinheiten mache ich
jetzt noch mit etwas pulver farbe da
habe ich jetzt wieder das grün etwas
schwarz und braun
[Musik]
so es ist geschafft meine world water
männern ist jetzt fertig und hätte ich
jetzt die probleme nicht gehabt mit dem
ganzen kühlen weil sie im hinteren so
warm ist dann werde er auch innerhalb
von etwa vier stunden zeigen jetzt mal
realistisch wäre dekoriert gewesen und
jetzt muss ich ihn anschneiden
das ist glaube ich immer so aber ich
finde es ganz gut weil dann wird
gegessen und dann ist er weg da muss ich
tun wollte nicht mehr sehen weil
irgendwann reicht's ich bin jetzt hier
diese optik gleich richtig schön
[Musik]
also für meinen wollte ich es leider
heute wirklich etwas zu warm
denn mir ist gerade der von dort
wirklich unter den händen weg aber ich
denke er schmeckt trotzdem sehr gut vor
allem so saftig und ich finde einfach
diesen effekt richtig schön mit diesen
kernen mit drin also mit diesem
wassermelonen kern mit dem
schokostückchen und was sieht es auch
richtig also das richtig schön saftig
schmeckt richtig nach erdbeere zitrone
etwas schokolade und ich finde das ist
halt so ein highlight kuchen den ich
zwar nie wieder machen werde weil einmal
wollte niemand das reicht wenn man
einmal macht und ja ich denke so viel
ein kindergeburtstag ist was aufwendiges
oder einfach mal so will man jemand
damit überraschen möchte und ich hoffe
dass euch diese anleitung jetzt gefallen
hat haben wir wirklich sehr viele
nachgefragt deswegen habe ich ihnen noch
mal extra für euch gebacken und jetzt
warte ich auf eure fotos und auf eure
wollte watermelon und freue mich darauf
wenn ihr mit die auf facebook und auf
instagram zukommen lassen und ja ein
anstrengender tag geht jetzt zu ende
ich freue mich schon aufs nächste mal
wieder biss dann tschüss und das rezept
gibt es - blog.de
[Musik]